so the fact that Mary Magdalene and
Jesus were using what is high-level
Tantra can it be experienced through
sexual Union absolutely but it is the
sexual Union is not the definition of
Tantra Tantra is when we experience
total communion with all that is total
communion with the Earth total communion
with your Divinity total communion with
every cell of your body total God
communion Source communion you have two
individuals that are embodying total
communion and presence what they were
doing was so holy brings tears to my
eyes it is the definition of what Isis
talks about in the Sophia code about you
know your sexuality being a pathway to
recognizing your true Divinity what are
you gonna do with that God communion in
your sexuality in Your Divine Purpose in
your creativity in your service to the
light that is the Tantra of full
beingness